given this film and its themes of kids
having to stand up to people that are
constantly telling them what to do the
thing do you feel like you're drawn to
two characters who are rebellious are
you a rebel no for my Collard shirt
whatever am i I think I'd never made
that connection until right right now so
I guess the answer is yes okay I am
drawn to that you know I think with with
this story is also drawn to that
friendship between the boys and the way
they explore making music is very much
the way I was in high school making
films that sharing in creating something
with somebody else and it was really
important to me and it was an easy way
for me to kind of get a bunch of people
together to socialize and work out stuff
that was going on with my with me so all
the things you could have done for your
first feature is that what drew you to
this story I think it was I think I was
really interested that this is based on
a novel by Peter Bayani and reading the
novel was an introduction of Buckminster
Fuller for me
I knew about geodesic domes I knew what
they what they were but I didn't know
about this incredible man and part of
the the draw of the novel was reading
about this guy that almost seemed like
he could be a fictional character and
but I think the heart of it the emotion
of it the thing that that really
attracted me to it was the story of
these these kids and and Meredith the
sister included I think because the age
that I really got into movies one of the
films that I saw at that age was
Breaking Away the Peter Yates movie and
it just had it has a really authentic
depiction of male friendship and and
also a story of class that I thought was
interesting which this film doesn't
really delve into but but I wanted to
try to have those kind of perform
winces in in a film like this and
portray friendship in a way that was
funny at times was maybe a bit sad at
times was what was always honest you did
not know that Ellen Burstyn and Bucky
were friends no so before that
realization happened what made her your
perfect Josephine I think she has a in
all of her performance has a Fergie's of
a kind of a lame way to describe but
like an earthiness and honesty about her
that Josephine had to have and an
unpredictability about her but she's
someone that immediately went when when
she popped in my mind is Josephine it
was just a good fit and I can't I don't
know that I could articulate it other
than other than that that just felt felt
right and and and it didn't hurt that
she's one of my favorite actresses and
she's amazing and we sent the script to
her and about two weeks after that I got
an email from my agent saying did you
know that Ellen knew Buckminster Fuller
and I said I didn't I did not know that
I did not end and he said well next time
you're in New York maybe we could set up
a meeting and I just said no I'd like to
go like now and so I'm open two weeks
later we worked out the schedule and I
went and met her tour at her apartment
and she told me the story of how she met
him and when she was shooting The
Exorcist and she went to hear him speak
and was really taken with with him and
then met him a few months after that and
one on one and then the friendship
sparked from there but she then showed
me the footage that you see you see in
the film which hadn't been never seen
before she just shot it and put it away
and put it on a shelf and it was kind of
the the one of these things where she I
went in still I'm like is Ellen Burstyn
really gonna do my little movie and and
but at the end it was like she was just
like how could I not but one thing that
came out of the scene where she slaps
ASA in the face that I wasn't expecting
was just how I knew I knew she was gonna
slap him because I'd written she slaps
was
he was we talked about it before he knew
he was gonna get clocked but the thing I
wasn't expecting was how she was really
affected by it more than him that that
and she she immediately felt like she
needs to apologize for that and that was
something that wasn't written in the
script that she she added and I remember
being like alright well maybe we could
try it I guess and we did it and of
course it and she was absolutely right
to suggest that yeah the music's a
character how did your actors feel about
Punk well so I think it's cool that you
said that it's it's a character because
it's how I thought about about it
because we started with we knew the punk
songs had to be stuff that Jarrod would
would be listening to that would be like
on his shelf or on his phone or wherever
you listen to music but then the score
came out of asking well what would set
what would Sebastian's soundtrack be and
mhm
during research for the film I'd been
watching a lot of Buckminster Fuller
documentaries and a lot of them are made
in the the 70s in the 80s and they have
this sort of cynthy retro futuristic
soundtrack and so the score is very much
inspired by those documentaries and and
we really liked the the counterpoint
that offered to to the Punk but as far
as the kids playing music alex is a
really accomplished musician and he he
was in a band with his brother and they
sent me an incredible audition tape
covering a song and I knew when I saw
that that he was the guy but he said did
not play the bass he really doesn't have
much music background and we had hired a
teacher to teach him the bass but
immediately Alex offered to do that
instead and we took him up on that and
it just bonded them in a way that yeah I
think really helped the movie and we
rescheduled the shoot so that all that
all the scenes that you see in the movie
when he's in the bass and in the woods
and he's plucking the bass that was like
the first day of shooting and he just
gotten the bass
started learning and at the end were
they play in the dome they had been
practicing together for a few weeks at
that point and actually played a show at
a bar so it was fun to chart and
parallel what was going in the in their
real life with what we shot the movie in
a lot of the the scenes were there
especially this the first scene where
they're practicing in his room for the
for the very first time much that was
improvised led by Alex just saying this
is how I would teach him this is how
good did you did you write the lyrics
for stupid school and what's the other
song going mad
no stupid school though that's pretty
much as as it was in the novel we we
made some tweaks to it I think just but
nothing significant and then the music
was done by this guy Mack Makana who's
in this band Superchunk
and he did an amazing job creating some
sort of tracks that the boys had for
inspiration and they sort of did their
their take on it
and that's sort of how we created the
sound for the band how much archival
footage did you plough through to find
that nugget well that the quotes so the
the footage itself was different than
the audio finding that some of that some
of the words written are written and
we're never actually recorded so we had
somebody a couple of close to somebody
who could do a great buckminster fuller
impersonation chord it for us and but
that that sort of idea was something
that initially with the script I had
actually originally thought that we
would cast someone to play buckminster
fuller and he would actually sort of
appear in Sebastian's mind mind's eye
maybe like driving his Dymaxion car or
standing in front of a dome and speak to
Sebastian and
and once we started kind of digging into
the film and seeing what was becoming
and also seeing how valuable the footage
of Ellen and Bucky was and how important
was to kind of stay true to that reality
it felt like a different movie to do to
do that so we we ended up leaning on the
archival more and I'm really I'm really
happy we we did I liked it well it's a
wonderful film and we can't wait to see
what you do next thank you very much
please help me thank Peter lavalla see
[Applause]